[Music]
you guys I'm Alexa Medina and this is
hashtag reality hi today we're gonna
talk about my 9 million followers can't
we be watching my name is Alexa mattina
and I'm a huge [ __ ]
hey babe yes Alexa you're in my shop
the truth is I'm just a goofy dog-loving
nerd good grades are hilarious I don't
think that that is what they're laughing
found him wandering the halls sniffing
this magic marker this is an outrage and
I deny all charges you have two friends
Freddie and grandma grandma is dead you
need to get some friends okay hey hey
I'm having a party Saturday you around
you should come
I think I could probably oh yeah oh yeah
I think I could swing that hmm this is a
bad idea you don't have the best
trackers people I didn't tell you this
is a boy oh my god I can see what camera
likes you thanks are you shopping with
us well I am one second I was in Malibu
in the next it was a freaking cute east
party later less like BFFs now I'm gonna
change my life have fun with your new
fake friends why can't you just be happy
for me
hey guys today we're gonna talk about
Dani burns she's a stalker you thought I
was just gonna let her steal my
boyfriend you've been losing yourself
Freddie you're my best friend I'm sorry
I was a jerk to you only way bigger jerk
I lost myself just to get likes from a
bunch of people that I don't even like
no offense
we know you the first person I have
about here are less special you are
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]